- A great operator, a great entrepreneur,
a great leader, a great CEO, like,
that's what you do.
You work for everybody else.
And when you're a great entrepreneur...
A CEO is a great leader in that time,
but she can leave in three
years and be a different CEO.
This is my baby for life.
This is why people struggle
with work-life balance
when they're entrepreneurs.
Your business is the next child.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
- Well, GaryVee, welcome to the A-List.
- Thank you so much.
- Now, you have a great
backstory and I feel like
the people who are watching this are going
to be in two camps;
either, they are just
stark raving mad lunatics
and followers of you on
every device they own,
or they're saying, hmm,
who is this young man?
And I don't mean to say that
from an older perspective.
- You're absolutely right.
- Yeah, so give us some background.
And I will say, I now
know, we were talking.
I've dpne so much research, that diet.
I don't know if you've heard of that diet.
The Whole30 diet.
- Yes.
- So I've been telling my
family I'm on a Whole Gary diet.
(laughing)
And I've been listening
to you so much that
our 14 year old got in the car yesterday
and there was only like
four seconds of your voice
and he goes, is that GaryVee?
I've got GaryVee.
So let's do it.
So now, he's on the GaryVee Diet.
- I love it.
Is the cursing okay?
Because I'm on not-televison,
there is some Jersey words in there.
- Yes, some.
Yes, I will just say
that I'm glad you brought
that up because the only F-word
we use in PBS in funding.
- Understood.
- Yeah.
(speaking faintly)
- So I was born in the Soviet Union.
- Okay.
- Which has had a huge
impact on my life because, A,
it makes me disproportionately
in love with America
and all its opportunities and I think it's
grossly-underrated even
through a lot of people
watching think it's a risk.
I think it's better than we even realize.
B, it means I grew up with very little.
We came to the US.
It was the late 70s,
the Jimmy Carter years.
The economy collpsed.
And we lived in a studio apartment
not bigger than this area that we're in
with six, seven, eight family members,
depending on the timing.
So it was very humble beginnings,
but a very loving family.
I have an all-time mom.
I'm sure, through your research,
you've come to realize she's
disproportionately my hero
and I give her unbelievable
amounts of credit
for who I am.
I was a super-entrepreneurial kid.
You know, it's very rare
for somebody growing up
in the 80s who's an immigrant
to not be blindly bought
into education as the way out.
Miraculously, I have such a great mother
who saw a four or five, I mean, young;
five, six, seven, eight year old kid
basically spend all his time on business.
Lemonade.
You know, I was a four-season executive.
In the Fall, I'm raking leaves.
In the winter, I'm shoveling snow
and singing Christmas carols at your door.
I mean, I literally, I
don't talk about that a lot.
I literally ran to
people's doors and be like,
will you pay us a dollar
to sing Jingle Bells,
me and my choir.
I mean, it was ludicrous.
- And you're Jewish, right?
- And I'm Jewish.
I mean, talk about,
I'm entrepreneur first.
In the spring, I remember we
did a miniature gold course.
We did mini-fleamarkets.
It was a garage sale.
In the summer, it was hardcore
washing cars and lemonade.
I was so passionate.
And then, very quickly, for
a lot of people watching,
they'll probably remember this;
in the late 80s, early 90s,
the baseball card phenomenon
in America happened,
and I was at the forefront.
Not only was I collecting
but, as a 12 year old,
I'm in hotel, in malls,
in convention centers,
set up as a dealer with other
30, 40, 50 year old men,
and really cut my teeth there.
And then, my 14th birthday came
and I, for whatever reason,
I guess, that's grownup in Russia-Land,
my dad, at this point, in parallel,
was also an entrepreneur,
a more significant one,
saved up all his money as a stock-boy
and then manager of a liquor store,
which is the job he got in America,
and bought a liquor
store and dragged me into
that liquor store in
Springfield, New Jersey,
when I was 14.
And so, from eight-grade on, I worked.
And so, from 14 to 18,
my high school years,
I fell in love with wine-collecting.
Because my dad had a
liquor store but it was
an affluent area of Jersey.
We were in a middle-class
town but everything
surrounding us was stronger,
and people would come,
and they would ask for wine.
And when I found out that
people collected wine,
that's when it clicked for me.
Because I wanted to help
my family business badly.
I wanted to be part of
the family business.
But I hated liquor and beer.
It wasn't interesting.
I didn't want to sell
Absolut vodka or Coors Light.
- But it was a great intersection because
you were selling lemonade
as an early little boy,
and then, you got into baseball.
So you knew there was a value in a thing.
That's why you collected.
So now, you're going to be selling--
- Beverages.
- [Alison] Liquor, yeah, collectibles.
- It's a great thought
that I haven't thought of.
So next we're...
(chuckling)
Yeah, and it clicked right away.
I became very passionate.
Went to college and, within
the first couple of weeks
of being in college, I saw the internet,
which was September of 1994.
I went into a dorm room.
I saw it.
It hit me.
And, over the next year,
I became infatuated
with what it could be.
And, in 1996, I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses,
one of the first two or three, four
selling wine on the internet;
called winelibrary.com, which is the name
that I wanted to call the business.
We were called Shopper's Discount Liquors.
So winelibrary.com was registered.
In 1998, I took over my dad's,
I joined the family
business and really became
the operator of the business,
because in my college years,
during the summer, especially, obviously,
it was clear to my dad
that I was a talented kid
and I was making things happen.
People are driving from two hours away
to buy $35,000 worth of wine,
and I'm 19 years old.
I'm not drinking.
But I was so outrageously
right about what wines
were getting hot, which wines
were getting big scores.
If you're watching and you know wines,
90 points, 92 points, that matters a lot.
Built a reputation long
before the internet.
And, from 1998 to 2005,
in a seven-year window,
I build my dad's business from a business
that was doing $3 million a year
to a business that was
doing $60 million a year.
And that, obviously, was a big deal
for an immigrant family.
- I think it's a big
deal, also, that your dad
was so flexible and dynamic in thought.
Because, I think, as an immigrant,
what I've found is they're like,
these are the rules we're going to follow.
Here's the goal and let's
not go against the grain
because it might cause
us to go back 10 steps.
He sounds accepting of what you're doing.
- My dad is historically
underrated for giving me
the air cover.
The reason I say that is, look,
when you, you know, I want to give my dad
unlimited credit because he deserves it.
But my dad's smart.
When you have a 16 year old son
who stands behind a register
but takes the initiative
to go through the entire Beverage Journal,
where you order stuff from,
finds a closeout of
sparkling grapefruit juice,
convinces the dad to buy it all;
it comes, it looks like
it came out of a cave.
But then, figures out
how to merchandise it
and make signs and sell it.
I gave my dad a lot of
reasons to give me air cover.
But, to your point, it
takes a level of humility
that most immigrants...
You want to get really scared,
and this is going to blow your mind DRock.
DRock is the man that
films me all the time.
So this is being filmed--
- We have some many cameras here,
I don't know which way to look, so.
- The day I started my
dad's store permanently,
1998, May of 1998, my
dad was 44 years old.
I'm 43 as of this second.
The fact, to think that
tomorrow my son or daughter
could be coming into VaynerMedia,
and I'm giving them the keys to run it,
is just laughable.
Not only did he give it
to me, the air cover.
He was a child.
That was kid.
You know, there's 68 year old right now
that are running the family business,
that are not letting their 44 year old son
take over yet.
There's 81 year olds watching right now
where she's not letting
her son or daughter
take over the business.
- Right.
- And they're 60 years old.
And my dad was 44 years old.
And, look, he did a
lot of backend keeping.
He was involved.
But I did all the buying.
I did all the marketing.
I did all the hiring.
I did it.
And so, he deserves an
enormous amount of credit.
And I think hundreds of
millions of family businesses
can learn a lot from my dad's strategy.
- Let's get into VaynerMedia
and VaynerSports,
all of these things that--
- [Gary] The Vayner--
- The Vayner Empire.
Also, the fact that,
by the time you're 60,
you're just going to be G.
Because you keep shortening your name.
(laughing)
I'm afraid you're going
to have nothing left.
Like, you've taken out the -chuk,
and now, you've taken out the -ayner.
And now, you're just GaryVee.
- If, in the next 17 years,
I'm able to market in a way
that I can trump Google's G
with my G, I'm going to do okay.
In 2009, my brother graduated college.
We had decided at that point we were going
to do something together.
I, in 2006, started Wine Library TV,
which was a daily show
I put out on YouTube
of me tasting wine.
That exploded, changed
the course of my career
in many ways.
One, it taught me that
I was a personality.
I didn't know that.
Two, it made my wine business explode.
Three, it made me go deeper
into what was called Web 2.0,
that now we call social media.
But these are slang terms
for the current state
of the internet.
That led me to getting
infatuated with Facebook
and Twitter, which led me
to investing in Facebook
and Twitter, and Tumblr
which, as you can imagine,
changed the course of my financial career.
It led to me writing a
book about the internet
and building reputation
and businesses on it
called, Crush It!, which was a huge
New York Times Bestseller.
Led to companies reaching
out to me and saying,
we're Pepsi and you have a
million followers on Twitter,
and we have 16.
That's weird.
We are ready.
And so, one day, I called
my brother and said,
ESPN just paid me $5,000
to come in for an hour
and talk about the internet.
I'm like, we should start
a company around that.
And I knew that I wanted
to build on my strengths.
I knew at 2009 that I wasn't
a great liquor store operator.
I was a great marketer, that I
could point that to anything.
And so, that's the
beauty of self-awareness
and a little bit of experience.
So we started VaynerMedia,
and the plan was
let's become an agency for brands
and let's build a great company.
And then, let's really
use it for ourselves.
Because having clients, at some level,
was not our interest.
I thought at the time, by 2015, '16, '17,
the economy would collapse again, a cycle.
Because we're just coming out...
We're building up.
We'll six, seven, eight years.
And then, when it collapses, hopefully,
the company will be good, and I'll be able
to have money and we'll be able to buy
a business for a penny on the dollar
because that's what always happens
when the economy collapses.
But now, it's 2019.
The economy has not collapsed in a decade.
As a matter of fact, it's over-frothy,
and the company's become enormous.
So the idea of building this small company
and then translating all he people
to the new company is out the window.
Now, much like Wine Library is doing well,
I want VaynerMedia to do well forever
even when I go and buy Snickers or Puma,
or whatever I'm up to in my next chapter,
which is going to be buying a business
and running it,
I want Vayner to do great and I think
a lot about that these days.
- And you want to own the Jets.
- I want to own the New York Jets.
- Which, we have a lot in common there,
I'll just say, because
I grew up in Alabama.
I'm a huge Alabama fan,
Roll Tide, and, of course,
love Joe Namath, who played for the Jets.
That's it.
That's the brige.
- I love it.
(laughing)
That's about where the
bridge ends because,
unless Roll Tide, who
win almost every year,
we lose every year.
- Yeah.
- And so, there's a big difference.
And, by the way, just
another little connection,
Richard Todd was also
an Alabama quarterback
who seems to be the blond Joe Namath.
He's pretty good.
He was my first quarterback
but he was no Joe Namath.
(overlapping discussion)
- How does that aspiration
fuel what you do?
Is it just, it it one of those things
you just keep, you've said it so long
that know it's become sort
of a mantra on the side?
Is that really?'
- Yeah.
- The answer's yes to both.
I mean, I, in somewhere
around third or fourth grade,
I don't remember exactly so
I don't want to make it up.
But before middle
schools, I started walking
around grammar school
saying that I was going
to buy the Jets.
It was a very big deal.
In middle school and high
school, it was the only thing
I talked about.
So that's a long time ago.
But I have created more
clarity over the last
two or three years because
I'm unbelievably passionate
about happiness, not about money.
As a matter of fact, I'm unbelievably
not motivated by money.
I've come to learn that about myself
in the last half-decade
because I'm leaving
a lot of money on the table.
I'm motivated by the process.
I'm motivated by waking up in the morning
and being fired up because I'm in control
of my destiny and I get to do what I want.
And that who I am.
I'm somebody who found what,
and I knew it from the beginning.
I didn't realize it.
But now, looking back,
as we set up earlier,
my early actions spoke
to what my passion was.
I always wanted to be in business.
I always wanted to sell
from the beginning,
from the womb.
And I love the chase.
I love the process.
- Which is why you're
the serial entrepreneur.
- [Gary] 100%.
- You've got to keeping building.
- Real entrepreneurs, which
is not what we have now.
We have a generation of fake entrepreneurs
because entrepreneurship is cool.
And I've benefited from that.
But I will not be a hypocrite or milk it.
I will speak the truth.
And the truth is, entrepreneurship
is extremely hard.
It's outrageously lonely.
Almost everybody fails.
And a lot of people right now that say
they're entrepreneurs
on Instagram are going
to not be entrepreneurs in three years
when that's not the cool thing,
when the economy collapses;
and I'm worried about
that because it leads
to depression and anxiety
and even the worst
of worsts, suicide.
And so, yes, that is why
I am an entrepreneur.
And that's why it's very easy for me
to know we're not living through an era
of real entrepreneurship,
because so many people that
I see are entrepreneurs
are actually executives.
- Do you think a show like Shark Tank
has been good for the
entrepreneurial spirit
or has it--
- [Gary] Both.
- Sort of--
- You're barking, yeah, of course.
- And has it made people
assume anybody can do it?
- It's been both.
What I like about Shark Tank is they show
a lot of people not getting a deal.
Thank God.
You know, what's bad about--
- I saw you on Shark Tank, by the way.
- Oh, yeah, I saw that
I flashed (mumbling).
It's kind of, you know,
I also am very passionate
about garage-sale-ing
The reason I don't like
all these flipping shows
and storage shows is it's
just a highlight reel.
Let me tell you, actually, what happens
if you go storage auction hunting.
99 of a 100 of them is a disaster
and you just paid $83 for dog poopy.
And then, you've got to clean it out.
You've paid to work.
- Right.
- So what Shark Tank has at least done
is show us, a lot of times, it's no.
It's hard.
It's just meeting, after
meeting, after meeting,
after meeting, and work,
and work, and work.
And so, it's unbelievably
lonely being a number one.
I'm worried about what's
happening in London,
LA, New York, right
now, and the well-being
of 900 employees.
Right now, I got an email on the way here
that the head of HR sent
something to somebody
that said, you and your
daughter are in our thoughts.
Now, I'm like, what happened?
I'm worried.
Like, you have 900 children.
Imagine having 900 children.
That's what it is.
A great operator, a great entrepreneur,
a great leader, a great
CEO, that's what you do.
You work for everybody else.
And when you're a great entrepreneur...
A CEO is a great leader in that time
but she can leave in three years and be
a different CEO.
This is my baby for life.
This is why people struggle
with work-life balance
when they're entrepreneurs.
Your business is the next child.
I have three children.
And that's the truth.
And maybe it's not the
most politically-correct
thing to say right now,
and everybody wants
more work-life balance,
but a real entrepreneur will
tell you dead in your face
in her or his truest moment,
my business is my other child.
It is my family member, because it is.
- Well, I'll tell you
what was very eye-opening
for me is hearing a lot of you,
hearing you speak a lot about,
and not just in one context,
but over and over again,
about your work-life balance
and, specifically, this idea
of breadth versus depth,
and that you're unapologetic
about working 18 hours
a day and all during
the week and, possibly,
not seeing your kids.
But when you are off-work,
you are in family.
And when you are in
family, you are off-work.
- That's right.
- But people are judge-y about that.
I mean, when people say--
- People are super-judge-y.
- Right--
- I'm judged here.
There's a movement of
people trying to make me
the face of overworking.
There are people right now using my name
to make a point that
we're glorifying hard work
because they're not spending a lot of time
looking at my content and
realizing that I'm talking
about happiness.
I'm talking about working hard to people
who are complaining.
If you're unhappy, and they,
this is 90% of the conversation.
If you say to me, I'm not happy.
I can't find my passion.
I don t like my job.
I'm unhappy.
My answer is to you is
work to find your way out.
Yes, I think, when you get home,
no, you should not complain about it.
You should not dwell.
You should not watch
Netflix or play video games
to escape your unhappiness.
You should try to start
an internet business
at night, because it's practical.
Because your grandma didn't have this.
And use it over a four-year period
to be able to go do that and quit your job
that you hate.
I don't tell people to work 18 hours a day
and burn out and have suicidal thoughts
when they're happy.
I'm talking to people
that complain and dwell,
and that is 90% of the market.
- And do nothing about it.
- Correct, but complain and dwell.
I'm an action-oriented dude.
I just don't know any other reaction
based on being an immigrant,
being kind of the man
of the house, because my
dad worked every minute.
All I know is problem, solve.
The thought of problem, cry, is completely
unacceptable to me.
That is what the masses do.
- So we talk a lot about hard skills.
What about the soft skills?
What about the skills that
I feel like we've lost
in every generation to a little bit extent
because we're not interpersonal.
Where we are relying on
technology to communicate.
Maybe, it's exposed up
but it also has allowed us
to go into our own silos and cocoons.
- Well, I don't know about that.
I mean, I think it depends
on how you define it.
So, to me, when I think about soft skills,
I think about things more like gratitude
and empathy and kindness, EQ,
really what I trade on, right?
I would argue that technologies allow me
to scale that.
Why is a letter or a
telephone that was rotary
considered so much better
than our cellphones
that are on us at all times, right?
The fact that, I'm looking at DRock.
The fact that I can text him a heart emoji
and he can know that
I'm thinking about him
and I appreciate him,
and I'm using soft skills
to show him gratitude,
yeah, I just don't agree.
I don't agree that--
- But is that heart
emoji gonna replace a hug
for your child?
- No, but I'm not there.
- I get that--
(overlapping discussion)
- No, no, let's stick
on that for a minute.
(laughing)
Is it going to replace it?
Of course not.
But what about when you're not there?
What about when you're
not thinking about it?
Again, why do we put some people,
you're talking semantics.
And when people talk semantics,
they try to put things
like a written letter
on a pedestal.
- Yeah, but I'm also talking that
I really couldn't care less
if my kids know calculus.
(overlapping chatter)
But I do care, and we have,
since the day they could walk and talk,
that they shake someone's
hand and look them in the eye.
- Right, and I have 4,000
times in the last six months,
made fun of people that
put that on a pedestal.
Not because I don't agree.
I agree too much.
You and I are kindred spirits.
That's probably why you've
been consuming so much
of my content.
I can tell already.
I knew it.
It's that I don't want,
what you're talking about
is respect, kindness, and empathy
for another human being.
- Yes.
- You've decided that
a handshake and looking
in the eye is the manifestation of that.
I don't believe that to be true or needed
in a world where things evolve.
I think the spirit of it is
more important than ever,
and always, actually, not more,
is always the most important.
But I am not going to require my children
to manifest it in what the correct state
of a politically-correct version of it is.
I expect them to act on it.
What I learned about
life is I've no interest
in trying to change your mind.
I love that every
family, and every parent,
and every little group of individuals
gets to decide what those
little trinkets are of it.
But I have no passion for my
children to be entrepreneurs.
- Right.
- I have a passion for my children
to be happy the way I am
because I'm an entrepreneur
and I was meant to be one for them.
And if that's an artist, or a parent,
or a student, or a professor;
and I think that's how I think
about the handshake thing.
I don't need to be
handshake-and-the-eye kid.
I need them to manifest kindness, respect,
caring, and things of that nature
and I think those rules evolve.
Those rules evolve.
Your great-great-grandmother
thinks it's insane
that you're wearing pants right now.
- She was pretty cool.
- But that's not what a
lady does in her rules
of you being a lady.
But I think you're a lady.
I mean that.
The Beatles' hair was unacceptable.
It just was.
And so, I'm not willing to take historic
or current social norms that
are the indicator of respect.
I actually want my kids to respect people.
- On that note,
(laughing)
thanks for being on the show.
- Thanks for having me.
(upbeat music)